Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Astroneer
Once again I'm joined by Wolfie, say 'hi'
W: Hi!
M: Hi, so uh, I just wanted to mention as we mentioned in the first one
uh uh
Like obviously we met through the Make-A-Wish foundation
Um, but- um, like, I'm sure that people want more details about what's going on
if you're willing to share them because it's - ohhh
we've got a storm incomin'
M: Get in the shelter ( x3 ) W: Oh god how do I be safe
M: Just jump in the pod ( x 2) W: There's only one!
M: Jump in my... not that
Why are you- what are you going to ride out the storm? Hang on, wait, actually, I'm gonna- if I could pick you up
O... pick... It won't let me... pick you up, get out of the freaking car, now get out of it- now get in
M: Okay, you're gonna be my shield against the storm. I'm gonna block...  W: I got this
M: the flying debris with your chair, and we'll get through here comes here comes. Oh, hey. Oh, heeeeeey
M:OW Ow Ow W:(untranslatable)
I'm dead that didn't work at all there asshole
Why are you go? God no Gotta fill it ow? Oh?
Fuck Oooooow
W: How am I perfectly fine? It's like hi poppy? M:OW my Body
My sweet delicious body. I'm dead again. Oh God all of my stuff... my testers, my everything... help!
Ow im dead again
W: every time you come back- M:Help Me im Dying
help
help meh ahhh
Watch from the sidelines. No help why won't you help me?
You're such a jerk, we had we had titanium and super valuable stuff. I got it
Why did I point at it pick it up? Where is it? Oh, you're dead now
Great, see this is what happens when you help people you die. Is that what happens?
Is that wha that's what happens now. It really happens. Okay. You picked up the titanium. I'm picking it up
You can keep all that stupid resin alright all that stuff that I got all that dumb stuff. Oh, yeah, okay, so anyway uh
We were saying so you're here probably gonna have to go through dialysis right right? Yeah, and for those that don't know
like dialysis is like A
Medical procedure of filtering out when your kidneys can't do the job, right?
correct yeah, so
it's something that's
Interesting because Tyler actually went through the same thing not the exact same thing in terms of like why he needed dialysis
But the exact same process and it it's really rough so like I got I got to commend you for
like taking with a brave face
Yeah, I'm what would the weirdest thing about it is um and I talked to
My doctor about it too and I said
I'm excited for my kidneys to fail and the reason being is that
I've been dealing this with this for nearly a decade now. Yeah, so
It's just finally like I see a light at the end of the tunnel Gotcha gotcha good. Yeah, well that's good
That's a big reason. I am I did youtube because
for God knows how long
I might you know not be able to
Get a normal job. I wanted to do military, but that probably won't work out because
I'll have had kidney surgery it might but I really I really come to love doing youtube yeah
So that's awesome
yeah, glad to hear and and
The only problems that I'm looking at with dialysis is like where you let me talk to Tyler. It's the whole
like you don't feel like doing anything, and you feel sick all the time and my fat old astronauts, not running there we go and
um
Otherwise you know I'm I'm just I'm fine. Yeah, I gotcha. I mean that's it
Oh, I found the compound mother lode get over here. We got a lot of farm. I am almost out of
Space I was going to say I came back because um
Yeah, the tethers ran out. Oh
That's okay
Because they're the blue stuff around it is what you need to be be able to
Blue stuff on the ground like the blue Squigglies that's oxygen you can gather that the same way you can Gather like power and whatnot
So that's awfully helpful, but I've got so much compound here. It is a awesome it is elson ah
Geez I shoulda came with a full backpack. Yeah, you shouldn't
Okay, I'm gonna go back help where I can yeah, you help out where you can wear your best needed
So you go get what you want to get good luck not
Asphyxiating don't die out there if you die out there. We lose everything so don't do that
I don't know about everything we lose everything. I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna make more tethers, and then I'll be back and we'll chain it out here, so that we can get more compound
But don't die
Yes
Yes, sir. Said don't die or die don't don't die don't die don't
Die get it out you got it donut donut. Yeah, all right cool, so I'm going to drop off some stuff
I'm Gonna make more tethers
I'm going to salvage some compound as we can but also I need to make more space on these bad boys here
So I need to extend the do burrs
Come on out and is is there we go oxygen. I'm not getting oxygen from this. Yeah the blue stuff is oxygen
Why are you not getting out in front? I don't know. I'm gonna Die well. Don't donna Donna die
Just oh goodness
What are you doing? Are you dying out there suffocating feels like no come on man. Did you die had small town?
Yeah, Georgia nice thing not to do and you do it
I'm a rule-breaker wait which way did we go just follow the x of my death. Oh, no you have no, I actually there
We go duke here. We go now such a big boy. He knows exactly where he's going
All right, come with me. I got more chattering what I?
Was Gonna take compound so that we could no leader come down there? I've got tethers you let me do the tiger all right?
I'm the boss here
That is how you're gonna keep going oh
You're the boss. I'm the boss here
Answers eyes all I gotta say about that
Make sense good. I think I made my point. I'm your uncle
Are you my dick and that's it?
That's all that I got I've got a bag full of tail all I have
Just your uncle. Here's your bucket and your grandpa always told me
Yep, think I made my point
All right, oh, shoot. I'm like you go up you go fat get fat to it. Yeah, I'd like a
Can I get a number uh?
You just gonna leave it yeah, so I'm s and then you pull up
And they're like you didn't order anything didn't amuse me I ordered
My favorite my favorite thing is we just always the the overly dramatic
Excuse me. I don't think you understand us works here
Excuse me. I love a good excuse me
All right dominus. I place the rest of the tediz going down into that cave
But we need to focus on the compound here, so there's tons of it. So just grab my hand
I'm filling up with it now okay cool. I'm gonna rake it right back. Oh, we get so much compound. Oh hurry up Cheez whiz
Why isn't your name Wolfie halt my name?
I can't be I already told you this I'm outside the box but not really because I was just like
No
Excuse me. I already told you this um ah
There you go, heavy ones believe it a nice quiet. Jog. Looks like that. Just after excuse me
excuse me I
got a bag full of apples and
Yeah, that's what I thought. That's what I thought all right. We got to make more
What is this?
And I'm Gonna make
Let's see
Point I'm just going to extend out these because for right now. I don't want to build platforms
I want to build a do bird eber's
Sweet 18h is a beacon
Within the H&H
Yes, what my H&M is a beacon?
What is a beacon anyway? All right? No? I'm Gonna make one
I
Wonder if it just tells you I died here. Yeah, probably just an identifying locator not really anything important
You probably shouldn't waste all your energy building one of those I'd be stupid to do that. You told me 20 seconds ago
Yeah, well I was like already met Joe. We won't lose our base now. I'll leave great
It wasn't like there was a giant home marker for that anyway, so yeah
I'm just gonna build some solar panels because that's something actually useful to do for this big. I have hydrogen
Hydrogen
That's you that's what you sound like look it, okay. I want to have it. No. I don't have hydrogen no get it
Oh, God, it's called Hydro come on excuse me excuse me check your priveledge
So I need more storage space. I don't have enough of it
So I'm just gonna drop it on the ground and what a look printer
do I'll print further than like like where we need to type it up and
Expect yeah good job there with your commentary very smart very oh my God. He's getting in the way
I asked them to take him out
Your ass here to take him out the teeth authority all right come with me
We're going into the first cave system because we got to go find some copper. We got to go find some aluminum
We need these heavy metal like your be able to do I need to do
Okay, is your inventory empty it better be and I have two things
I'll just drop them because it's organic
Yeah, you don't need a riparian compound all right? I'll just keep that in case we need more tethers
Yeah, okay, you do that because I don't have any more - other way
oh
God, I'm falling there. We go. Hey. There's a something down here
There's like someone kind of like satellite. There's a lot of things down here hmm wow, thanks, man
Also, what is it?
It's so goopy. I don't know but there's like you peeing why is there? What is this? It's a satellite
There's a Frickin satellite down there what but why is a satellite under down? Wow it hurt me it killed me
Yeah, don't go wait what?
It killed me. I got you. I jumped I jumped on that goopy thing
I know
I know, I shouldn't jump on goopy things and inulin I found some I found a dead body down here and has dynamite on it
I've never seen dynamite in my life business
Whoa, definitely shouldn't get it? I'll take care of all that. You know awesome and the case happened. Oh, why don't you?
And that time comes with the design you got dino
Okay, I think I see some a valuable resource down here. It's gonna try to grab it and try to grab it
I'm coming this time. I ever backpack. Oh
Wow
That'll do that. It'll free your back. Oh malachite that's copper ore that's right. That's copper ore. That's good. Okay
This good, but you good. Oh, I did I
done died
It was the green gasps
Dammit
Dammit are you banging their ass yeah? The gas there's like the plants that shoot green fart gas at you
And if you breathe it in and you'd die
Which doesn't make any sense like we got we've got we've got like Frickin helmets yeah helmets
Yes is the word. I was looking for we've got helmets. Yeah, we know breathe your air
We breathe us air on the higher get better us air better. Good. It makes good air do
It taste more good. Don't take my feet off the feathers down you press t
T put them back in your inventory press t got it
Got it. Oh jeez that was good. I was done breathing. Yeah, you got it. I don't I don't topic 8 I
Unknowable like in the water oh God. Oh God. It's following me. Yeah, don't let it get you
Don't let it get you whatever you do. Don't let it get you
Are you letting it get? Yeah? You shouldn't let it get you following me so far. Yeah
I know it boy likes to do that. It wants to do that. Okay. I got a
Patent that oh. Yeah your farts, okay. I gotta go back. You're on your own screw you. I hate you
No, way, whoa? I found you dead body
Now my just know someone about someone else's up. I don't know I didn't die there
Huh, what are you talking about never dies
Well you I never died I died died two weeks ago that I think died to me
Yeah, that's exactly how that is we think I'm crazy
Yeah, yeah, I'm crazy. Whatever oh, I got a research
Cool good for you, bring it back. I've got copper
I'm gonna put in the smelter and this copper is going to be able to turn into some old fart on me. Oh, God
It's harding on me, okay. All right run faster. Thank you
So I'm gonna smelt up this stuff like the boss. I am
Hey, uh-huh walked when you smell
point shout
Sweet ice I'm strong through that door?
I'm smelling up a crazy storm, and then I'm Gonna build a printer oh cloud
Smelting class yeah, we're gonna refer
We're ruining this this place the beauty of this place is being like horribly thrashed
Because we keep filling it with our smaller. It doesn't matter we need thing
the environment can take the hit yeah
Whatever anyway, I'm building a friend or now
Just so you know I built a printer. I forget oh, God
I fell don't why didn't you let me make that hole you fell in whoo? Why'd you fall in the hole?
Why did you do that? Oh my god? Oh this soul has a good point the solar panel is freaking out
Oh my God, you're so far away. Can you just run and pick this up for me? So I don't have to
No, I cannot I will not respect that respect
Thanks, thanks for respecting it
I like to take initiative and all that I do I think I think it deserves all the respect in the world oh
Yeah, and I appreciate you understanding that all right. I got to build one of these is the
crock open and egg
Open research station, you dummy
That one. I did it yeah the research station Irie not taking this one good
Oh at least you did it right this time excuse excuse me rocks
Excuse me get out of my way
was it
Whatever model narrow mom. Wow that was a useful research, man. I'm so glad
Oh maude. Oh, you don't know what an arrow Rod Maude is
I'm crying
I know what I narrow maude is I thought you were an expert at this game man seems like there are some things that you
Understand I don't that I want to know you know so you explained it. Oh. Oh, you'd like that if I explained it well
I'm not gonna give you the satisfaction of me and explaining it because that's too good for you
Yeah, got you there. I got you there. Oh my God nichy knows
Why today of all days what why why?
You used tricking me with Dodgy nose. Oh
No, it's impossible
all right, I'm gonna go back in the cave, so
You can either join me or die. That's what you can do. I'm a moment now your rooming them
I'm moving them I gotta find a moving them a moving them. Oh a moving them
You need to go down in the caves, and you need to scavenge more bullshit, and you need to get it make sense Cooler myself
Yeah, also get more researchable because those are important heck
Yeah, I think I found one there was another one over here somewhere. Oh
Poison Hatch just
Run from it. I can't run what I have the researchable, but I'm Gonna Try I
Add string key all my dynamite. How can I forget my dynamite?
Yeah, just blow it up. Maybe I did yeah, maybe I can't blow it up. I'd like to think I could blow it up you
Okay, I'm not trying to get over there. I've got gaseous
following me
Sucking on something. Yes, suck harder
Resin I don't need a fucking person. Oh what you lively rock your damn language
What's your fucking language Abou this isn't my wolfy this isn't the Wolfy I know the Wolfy
I know what I say fuck. Oh
YouTube changed you man, did Youtube change you hardwired changed you man?
How could you let that happen?
You betrayed us. I knew you when you were just luke what happened dude
Now your mole feet and ah gross you didn't even spell it, right. God. Oh supid. Yeah, is it wolf hey?
What is wrong with you? Yeah? I just
Yeah, took my my book
What book whose book whose book I should open to a tether
Yeah
You sure did didn't you you goof alas nothing whole history search hang on this why usually stay far away from big holes that I?
want to dive on in well you're only good at sucking you're not good at filling big holes so don't do that ah
Well, I knew it had to be one or the other why did I pick sucking hey, we got a medium center area
Alright, I got a uh
Hydrazine, I think excuse you what still did you just say do it? What are you talking about?
I have hydrazine for the medium generator isn't that how
Generations of work sure I guess hey. I'm gonna come over to you, and I'm I passed out my dynamite, okay?
Okay, Doc. Let me see if there's a specific control to test out the dynamite all aleady
Give me that evening d is turn right? You stupid goof is it? Why might?
Wow
Yeah, yeah, you should feel tom. Just cut that part out none of us don't go on in
nah-ah uh yeah
No, see that's the thing about youtube you can't cut out anything mistakes live with you for life
You have to let people judge you on them. Yes, please everyone judges me. So they have to judge you too. All right
I'm Gonna Build
I'm gonna Build a few more tether e weathers, and then I'm gonna go into de-rate. I don't know what's Gonna
Go this way, but I'm going what is an arrow mod, wait. I can build an arrow mod. I'm gonna
I'm gonna build a bigger sure it's what you put in your eye on prey
What oh, God? Oh God storm? I'm running an arrow mod if I'm building our words neuroma. You know I
like
It there you go and Augie thought I meant like go to the church and pray to the father no
I didn't think you meant that at all. I didn't even hear the word pray here
I don't know you being done because you're out in the middle of nowhere when a storm's rolling
I hung it in the head with a rock you know what I'm Gonna build a really big hole and go in it
to see you dive in
Good luck in there
Dude, it doesn't matter that I get out it matters. You could have just come over here and getting in the Pod I
Didn't think I'd make it. It's like not a bit smart eh yeah. No the rocks aren't even there yet
Is it still dead storming gor missed you entirely it didn't even hit us I?
Wasn't even here excuse you who gave me this idea who gave you the right who told you who my dad was?
Where did you find my uncle how could you I?
Think I made my point bigger bait it all right
I've got an I've got an I'm gonna narrow my heart come to kill me
What's the fricked of the narrow Mod do I don't know stick it on something? I did it didn't seem to go nowhere
It's on this research station, but that doesn't seem to do it it. Well. I'm looking at your guy and my guy
who
I'm really big. Oh wait handle. Oh, that's how you do the Dynamo you set it down
And then you just blast it okay all right off that mountain. Yeah, I'm gonna plug you read my mind, Mr.
Wolfman you read my mind
You and I we're gonna blow the fuck out of this mountain
I'm gonna teach it and you've been learning how to suck all these years, but now
Now it's time for me to teach you the sacred art blow oh
Get ready buddy here. We are ah
Yes, this isn't real nice here. I can already feel like a reverb of blow coming on. Oh yeah
it's the blow coming back three it through the through the various uh
Mountains here we go you have to light it off now. Go back, whoa
Whoa not very impressive behind you know it's good enough. You know bad. I'm gonna Dig in news Mom ah
I'm gonna dig up this then cool. You do that. Stupid. Nope. It's too hard. I give up already ha ha ha oh
Man, hope you don't actually commit to anything else in your life. Go fuck
I love digging digging it so bad seems like this is a bad idea to keep digging down here, but you know what?
Okay, oh, God. No, just just dig straight down
you got to land on something what have you fall through down to a precipice um
Let me show you
Bye. Oh my God goodbye. Oh
I haven't fallen yet. I don't know where I'm going. I'm gonna try to put tether down there for you. Oh gasps. Yes
Yes, I try. I'm trying to build tethers, but they didn't they didn't land. God she's gonna dedicate her second good along
Yeah, I think that's a good place in this episode. So thank everybody for watching
Wolfies Gonna deal with this guy's problem down there
So uh thank you everybody so much for watching any last words will be
That helped me. Nope. Can't do so thanks again, and as always we will see you in the next video